[Music]
[Music]
is oh what a lad and i know a lot of you
will be happy with today's guesses i've
had about a thousand requests to get the
sled on last week after his little
post-match interview went viral he's a
proud wellingtonian who started off with
the wellington lions but has since moved
up to bar plenty and over the life of
the last few years has been a big part
of the chief side putting in some big
performances for them his parents are
also incredibly good lawyers and as you
guessed he is an absolute lad it is one
of the greatest
oh
what a little plug there for my parents
like
[Laughter]
what's good guys what's good man
oh man i'm feeling good energy from you
i know why so many people wanted you on
i'm in man i'm happy to be here right
i've been uh waiting for my turn i've
been waiting for my turn
well your time has come and mate
obviously i spoke about the um mention
the
interview the interview that went viral
mate how's your how's your life changed
post there
oh how did i hear the boys are probably
sick of me talking about every day and
if i'm with them and someone brings it
up they're like bro
don't don't talk about it
but it's been good it's been good
i was pretty crack of like i was
honestly just talking to those guys and
like if i talk to guys that know me
they're like yeah you were just yawning
but a lot of guys are like man this is
so cool you'll blow around like
[ __ ] i was just yarning yeah yeah
was that your first interview because i
haven't seen you like sort of doing it
to you before obviously this one's just
blowing up was that sort of the first
one that was my first one i was pretty
rattled before because i was scared
they're going gonna ask like if you if
you watch the interview they when they
ask stuff about footy [ __ ] i am guessing
hey i was like they were just looking
like the game was like um yeah uh games
were good but yeah when they when i
started talking they i just thought it
was like i'm just gonna um and then they
started talking about my nails and then
i was like bruh he's just gonna talk
about my nails i might just you know let
me let me be me right now you know i
mean
well once they got you singing mate it
was all over right on yeah that was all
over the 100 100
but has it taken you like three years to
get one interview right you must have
just been waiting you looked ready
yeah honestly it's funny i i took the
gusty out so you got to give me one of
these gigs man you got to give me a sky
sport or something that to just give me
open brain he's like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then when that happened i
didn't actually know i was there as a
man of the match i just thought because
i was talking to someone there was like
come on spock and then they said that i
was like oh stroke because i came off in
like 50 57 minutes so i was like right i
don't think i played that well if i'm
going to come off there early in the
game yeah and then they sit down sweet
and then yeah so i was kind of waiting i
was just sort of like thinking i was
thinking like if i was to be in a do an
interview i would just sort of like be
myself so it sort of worked out in the
end and i'm glad that the way it came
out the way that people saw it was i was
actually being myself because i feel
like if i was talking and being someone
else then it would be so hard for me to
keep up the same facade so yeah yeah
worked out at the end i guess right
that's it i love seeing it and you
mentioned big gas
um he he's obviously had a bit of an
influence on you i know that you're
roaming with him a lot
um what sort of
advice has he given you oh
he tells me to stay humble which is
probably one of the main ones which is
pretty rich from that guy um
he's been good bro he's actually been
good i think they ruined us last year
because we were both one of the loudest
guys on the team and then yeah we just
sort of
some of our chats outrageous in the room
i probably wouldn't don't want to
elaborate too much but um
yeah it's funny because i always ask
them about certain things and we always
actually have real real deep
conversations about um about life and
because he's also he's always you know
he's uh how old was he 48
i'm 22 so
it's sort of just
different guys in different pathways of
their life so let's lastly a room with
that guy and listen to his uh his story
because he's actually got a mean story
yeah he's got a he's gone through a lot
in life so yeah yeah yeah he was one of
my favorite podcasts to be fair mate
just such a funny guy such a good story
yes yeah mates you guys get to room
together because no doubt you'd be
having some
classic yarns but
oh hey
it gets way off sometimes actually
freeway off um but yeah that is good got
a lot of time for that guy he's
obviously very comfortable in front of
the camera have you always been
comfortable in front of the camera
um
yeah yeah i sort of like enjoy that side
of footy and
um
put it on a show i guess so yeah i do
get rattled quite easily especially if
they start talking about footy because
yeah i'm not that big of a code hidden
and especially if we talk about footy
after a game like if i'm if i'm having a
good game then i honestly don't even
remember the game yeah so i
when i was talking to those guys i was
like
what did i do
and then they were saying this and then
i was like oh i was just going to go
back to the air it's a gamer too hard
you know creative to the boys put it to
the ladies in the kitchen i just got to
start whipping these lines off because
honestly i was like
what even happened so
yeah okay note to self no footy chat
yeah no footage i've got none i've got
none for you
well i know that you're a big man on
swish so i bet the swishers were flowing
in last week after the week cameo right
my swish is so dry
oh my god i've got nothing out i've got
nothing bro shout out to swish if you
need you know talk with some you know
some messages i've actually yeah when i
when i first got on the switch i was
like [ __ ] no one's gonna mail me and
then yeah no one's mailed me
[Laughter]
but yeah man if you guys need something
very come see me now you know it would
be nice to
probably you know for a bit of chat
around and switch mate i checked up i
was expecting you to be around that 300
mark you're down there at the 30 mark
you're an absolute still get amongst the
listeners
i am humble on that swish tank right now
i need a i need some people to come in
and show me some funny love
oh
that's good stuff but i know you did say
you don't like talking footy but you
have been playing some unreal footy i
mentioned that you are my i'm fantasy
rugby team you've been piling up the
points for me when you've been given an
opportunity
and you do have pretty tough competition
up there obviously three other all
blacks to compete with your locking spot
but have you found it have you found the
season so far
uh season's been good um i sort of knew
uh
that it would it would be sort of like
this and it's pretty cool because when i
first came into the chiefs we just had
michael allendy's tyler adron i think
covert happened and then they had left
and it was just me and toops yeah mitch
brown he's not even a block he's a six
and they're sort of just us learning
from each other um and then two came all
black later in that year and then
last year
again it was just us two so we didn't
have anyone to sort of you know learn
from we were just sort of learning from
each other and then
this year's been cool because it's been
the most uh competition i've had in the
in a
in the team
we got josh lord who became all black
last year toops who's um playing unreal
he's been playing i'm real since he got
on the scene and then big guzzler he's
you know the goat so um it's been good
um it's been a good year the cultures um
the culture here is unreal and um i
think every year i've been here the
team's just getting tighter and tighter
so it makes for makes for good times
yeah good stuff what does ghazler like
um to learn off he's a man here honestly
uh when he first came in um i was in awe
of that guy i was like uh hopefully and
then um when he was
we would have like line-up meetings and
that guy's like he's playing chess i'm
playing checkers i'm i'm thinking of the
next line and he's thinking like he's
thinking too long at the head i remember
asking what do you do he goes well i'll
i'll jump here to see up to see the
defense here and then if they do this
then i'm gonna jump here i was like
bro
this is like
way off chat for me yeah um so it's been
cool it's been cool living off that guy
same as same as tips as well her tips
has come come back and learn heaps and
since being all black so
those guys yeah good to learn enough
mate awesome and every time you've been
given an opportunity you've really put
your hand up
have you found your own personal form
um yeah it's been good i think i feel
like
um that's like what you're saying like i
i've tried to come on and make an impact
um and i'm sort of solidifying my role
in the team as an impact player which is
um
not ideally where footy player would
want to be but for me
i just want to do
whatever it takes to to get a win and um
so it's been good um i feel like yeah
coming off the bench i've been adding a
little bit of energy and a bit of a bit
of flair and um
you know lifting the tempo so um
yeah i've been enjoying it yeah you've
been on absolute fire but we will end
the footy chat there but i do want to
hear from your story from the start like
all good stories
all good movies all good books we need
to start at the start um take us back 22
years ago
when the young nato was just born and
growing up um yeah i was
obviously i was born in wellington
i don't know how what else my parents
are brown
and what else what am i trying to talk
about so i born in wellington um
born in brentwood until i was 18. went
to her title school with uh with billy
proctor
and then he went to scots and then i
yeah yeah yeah that was back in the day
and then um
went to wellington high in my first year
of school which is like an alternative
school that no one really knows about
and then i went to wellington college
for my
last four years um i just went to
wellington high because my parents
actually handed the form in late so i
actually wasn't even accepted into cole
which was [ __ ] yeah that was like i
was like what the how can you how can
you get that wrong
that's my question like
how what is going on in your life for me
to not be important you know anyways
that was what was happening then um
yeah spent did most of my footy um at
wellington college uh played
uh for them and then for my club uh
marissa and pets uh junior rugby and
then when i left college i went and
played a bit of senior rugby of the year
before um
did an opportunity with the lines and
then
um
an opportunity with the chiefs so yeah
all right that's probably pretty brief
for you you've raced through that and i
love it but by all accounts you're an
absolute gun from a young age wellington
college is it true that you made their
first 15 at year 10. that's unbelievable
yeah on your
that was my first year at the school and
then
um i don't even know what happened i
think i i wasn't even gonna play for
them and then i did one trial game and
then i went off and played was playing
aussie rules um and aussie and then the
team had got named and um my phone was
blowing up and then yeah once i got in
there i never left i guess so
yeah it's been pretty it was pretty fun
footy out there and um i remember people
coming back to colder so if this is the
best what do you ever play you're
thinking
like surely the professional rugby is
cool but in men you you get into the
game you realize bro that's that's
[ __ ] living out there right
yeah you mentioned aussie rules there
though so when did you start playing
aussie rules and how did you get into
that
um
i was playing aussie rules because my
brother was playing it and then when i
went to colla cole
i started playing it again and then
yeah i think from year 10 up to
almost my maybe to year 12 i was playing
it um i was doing that in a bit of water
pilot um which was pretty cool
and i think my year 11 year year 12 year
my coach sat me down and was saying if
you want to
play afl or water polo then do that but
if you want to play footy do that as
well or like you have to do that so it
was sort of like a i was at a crossroads
in my second to last year of school and
then i chose rugby um i'd never really
looked back since but yeah i did a
couple years
of
aussie rules which was pretty mean
traveled to australia a couple times
which was awesome and then
i played a water polo which probably
might make three sports
or through my
um
what they call intermediate and
primary school and then once i got to
college decided to drop off and then
just play full on rugby um but yeah what
made you choose rugby out of the other
over the other two
um
i wanted to go to i actually wanted to i
was like
in my year 10 years i thought it'd be
pretty cool to
play water polo in university we
traveled to hawaii when i was in year 10
um and that was a cool experience and i
was thinking this would it wouldn't be
me this would be pretty mean
and then afl was cool
um
but yeah i think i've just been a rugby
guy ever since ever since i was born and
there was the dream of being an all
black and a professional player was
probably um
outweighing um those sorts of uh
dreams i guess for me yeah and what's
water polo like to play it looks looks
like a nightmare of a sport for me who
hates trying to start float right
honestly it's it's pretty hectic like
it's quite physical um the brass neck
retiring um knackering is even a word
i'm tiring and what else was gonna say
oh yeah honestly there was then there
was just no brown people in the water me
and my brother and maybe this other dude
in auckland we're like the only brown
people
we just look [ __ ] way out of sorts
but yeah um i've probably i was probably
um that was probably my best sport i
feel like i was probably
better at waterproof than all the other
sports but
um bro it's a it's a tough sport i
wouldn't be able to just pick it up
again
swimming fitness and rugby finish two
different things
and yet honestly staying afloat is
probably
something i can't do for a long time at
this point in time of my in my life so
yeah
and what about afl um you obviously must
have a good decent kick on you
i beg myself back myself um you have to
ask a few guys on the team you know but
um it's actually way different kicking a
um
aussie rules board than a footy wall but
um
yeah i've i've uh
i bet myself yeah do you think you'd be
able to compete at that now
afl
ah
we went we played a win in melbourne we
went past a few um stadiums that i
played and i was like
those are [ __ ] huge can i swear on
this yeah mate be you oh yeah yeah yeah
a whole slot right those are mess about
and those guys run [ __ ] 10k whatever
um but i feel like i feel like if i gave
it a crack i could probably do it but
i'd probably have to lose 10 kilo um
and then do a whole lot of different
training but yeah i beg myself i guess
any desire to do it at some point or nah
nah
nah the losing 10 kilo part is probably
like probably 10 kilos like 15 kilo
that's probably like
[ __ ] you're asking a lot of myself you
know there's a lot of sacrifices that
need to be made but um yeah ah we'll see
but i don't see it in the near future
that's for sure so then what was your
pathway from school you obviously chose
the rugby pathway and wellington college
um first 15 for four years
uh out of school you're obviously pretty
hot property i'd imagine a lot of people
try to
sign you i know here at tasman they
still call you the one that got away but
oh nice any other teams try and get you
[ __ ] i appreciate that
um i think it was me it was probably
when i left school i played new zealand
schools and i had already signed with
wellington before that and then i
remember
i talked to tasman those guys were
really cool i can't even remember the
guys names but they actually came over
came to my house
sat me down and
their pitch was awesome a lot unreal um
i still talked to next about it to this
day like what could have been but um
and i remember i honestly remember like
i remember going to talking to my mate
about what i got at wellington or like
the marcos and he was like bro you no
one even knows who the marcos are we
didn't really watch like npc yeah and i
was like yeah 100 percent like who wants
to live at nelsonville who's leaving the
marcus and then lo and behold [ __ ]
we're just getting pumped by the movie
working like
we did at the microsoft so
yeah um
yeah that's probably just those two
those two got those two teams at the
time it was
uh wellington mccains and then
tasman had come
and they were with uh the crusaders so
sort of those two guys but um
yeah what could have been i guess what
could have been down there and what was
your time like in the um wellington lion
lions academy uh it was fun um
it was a cool first year like i was just
my first year so just going for a ride
and then
we ended up making the finals and losing
to you guys
um which was a it was a cool final day
like i've never been in a fine without
burgeoning
we will
remember just being on the sideline and
then the
the crowd's so close to us saying just
giving us [ __ ] as we're warming up i'm
like [ __ ] this is mean like this is so
cool um and we felt like we were in it
for most of the game and then
i'm pretty sure next just went in like
he must have caught kickoffs and just
ran like
made a break every every time he caught
a kick was and i can't remember because
i was on the sideline but i was like
[ __ ] this was cool but i spent that year
there and then another year um
my last year uh 2020 um and it was fun
yeah it was pretty cool got a bunch of
people and uh it was cool to sort of be
representing my home and were you still
living at home uh during this period
because yeah yeah by all accounts you're
a bit of a mummy's boy yeah yeah oh i
wasn't living at home i was living i was
living with my missus um
at their house i sort of moved from like
my mom looking after me to my missus
looking after me and sort of
sort of just if i went back home would
be the same and if i went back if i
would have done this is the same so i'm
sort of like home and my mom or mrs
and food and the other things that come
with him and missus so i was like sort
of just outweighing halloween
i'm a little bit yeah yeah yeah i live
with my music we lived in strathmore for
a couple years
um which was mean i'm living with her
mum as well her mom's great as well so
um
yeah and we got a heap of questions
about the headgear um you obviously
write mum on your headgear every week um
what's the story behind that one um so
it probably isn't really too much of a
story it's sort of just the fact that
i'm a mummy's boy and um
i i started wearing headgear i meant
college and then
just thought i'd just chuck it on one
time and i was like [ __ ] this is quite
nice and i've just left it ever since
then
um a lot of guys think my mom's dead or
my mom's got cancer but i'm like oh
she's
she's probably on the person right now i
don't
know
she's a good way she's a good lawyer
she's a good lawyer one of the great
lawyers um she's probably doing you know
at a law firm she's probably doing it
you know at a law firm and you know
diving into political things and other
things you know what lawyers do but um
yeah so she's she's she's alive and well
and healthy um i just love her a lot i
guess yeah
because you've got pretty hissing hairdo
too so have you ever been tempted to
sort of let the headgear go and let the
get the hair out
look at that i actually wore i wore it
um against the canes when i started
against the canes we beat the canes
early in the year i didn't know where
he'd get no one really noticed um but i
actually just left my i can i left my
head gear
here and i've got in the and i was like
[ __ ] my again in i was like oh well i'm
just going to try and um go without a
head gear so it was pretty it was pretty
cool ring without hair gear um but i
feel like i'm building a bit of a brand
with the head gear so
i should keep it on and then and then we
played against the reds and i was like
that was so human i was contemplating
not wearing head gear and then
i watched tips have like a head-on head
collision and i was like [ __ ] putting
my head on because yeah i don't want
another concussion so yeah
have you ever looked as far as
potentially starting your own sort of
headgear brand with mum on it is that
where you're thinking
yeah see
that's sort of yeah something like that
i think i feel like there is probably
um if i keep this long enough i could
probably build a bit of a following with
it and yeah i haven't thought too deep
into it but i can see that there is
potential for that
to happen for me so
we'll see we'll see huge man i couldn't
i can imagine going down to
saturday early morning footy all these
kids have this headgear on it oh that'll
be living and you are just making bank
yeah that's it
that is it right there
yeah that is 100 because i actually
sleep like i don't know i actually see
people in wellington
like having something on their head gear
some guys have mom and some guys have
like they actually have like other other
things on and i think [ __ ]
that's it right there that's that's
that's something i could jump into so
if i can be bothered i'll probably try
give it a crack
you'll get there could even be like a
little white board where you can write
whatever you want on there how good is
that yeah
yeah yeah a whiteboard change it every
week yeah you can just sort of don't
even know rub it out and then
every week you represent anyone you
represent your missus then your kids
then your church then your side lady
whatever you want you you go you put it
on there my bruh
yeah
even change it at half time hey you know
every 20 minutes bro you know you score
a try rub that off screw another try
frame
representing someone else yeah so that
works they you could be honestly there
my brother oh yeah
so you obviously played a couple of
years with wellington
um how come you never played for the
hurricanes and why did you move to the
chiefs what happened here
uh um
i had an opportunity to come
to the canes when i because if you
remember i did like itc
you were there i remember very well yeah
yeah yeah yeah so i'd like to see with
the canes
um
and then i went to twenties and they
were there were talks about me signing
and then i didn't make the 20s um
and then
i
um came back and then didn't hear from
them
until
i didn't really have didn't really hit
them until like the lion season and then
um the chiefs had come and i was
like [ __ ] this would be cool and as the
chiefs had come i was
i found out i was having the kids and i
was like
i can either stay here and do another
like
another pre-season and work on the
bloody roads or i can go to the chiefs
and um try make some money so
it ended up it ended up working out for
me i'm i'm happy with my decision
and i love it up here so yeah why did
you miss out on new zealand 20s um i
thought you made new zealand 20s
uh i made the 20s
i made new zealand 20s the
team before the world cup and then i um
i was at the whatever that tournament is
in australia and then i was
so tired this one day
when i took a nap um
and then
i was with my roommate and then um took
a nap woke up checked the time and i was
about 40 minutes late and after this
[ __ ] i was like oh we gotta get up we
gotta get up look to my locked another
bed and my room is gone i'm like oh
sweet ass um i won't name the room
because you know that's just i don't
want to do that but then bro and the
elevator going down is see-through yeah
so i'm going down
and like prior to the training is a
meeting so i'm going down and the boys
are freaking warming up and i'm like
oh my days i can see them warming up
i've realized i've missed the meeting
i've missed probably half the warm-up
and i come down i just was like [ __ ]
trying to get changed i'm trying to put
my boots on i just jump in the wall and
i just jump and bro and then but we're
doing passing drills i'm dropping
everybody i'm like i am so grateful here
oh oh so i missed the medium probably 10
minutes of the warm up and then after
the training the coach comes he's like
what happened bro guys well i just slept
in um
and then he just said i'll sweep make up
for it in the game and you should be
sweet and then bro i've i rolled my
ankle so bad not the first five minutes
of fiji um we played fiji and then i
came off
and then got sent home and i was like oh
well that's the end of that so
yeah that's
i don't i don't know if that's why i
lost 20 there could be other reasons but
i feel like if you're 40 minutes late to
a to a meeting and then 10 minutes late
to a training it's probably
something uh that contribute to not
making the team so i haven't asked the
coaches i should probably ask them and
see what their thoughts are but yeah get
some closure on it yeah yeah it was here
it's all up in the air at the moment
there's no worse feeling than knowing
that you're late to a meeting when you
first realize and you'd see the time and
your heart just dropped honestly um i've
been late i [ __ ] my i was useless like
at that part and then like my first sort
of lines
um i was late a couple of times and one
time i came late one time i came late to
training and then gabo the he's the
keynes coach now just sent me home for
the week for the week
yeah yeah oh it was like it was the
trial week it was the trial week and i
came late on monday i didn't tell anyone
i didn't really know the etiquette of
when you're late
i thought you just like try and slip him
and then i came in and
one of the boys like [ __ ] did you did
you did you call mills like the manager
i was like no he's like
oh [ __ ] he's our sweet try and slide in
and then i walked in i'm trying to warm
up and get where it comes and he's like
right talking about he was like where
you been i was like oh i've just been in
the and uh and i'm studying goes [ __ ]
man i've been looking for a man get out
i'll call you when i need you and i was
like
brian i had to walk my prep my dad had
dropped me off and then he had gone to
work so i had to walk from new town to
call bernie and bro there was a lot of
deep thought happening in that in that
wall i was like
it was so bad so
i've had a few times where i've been
late and it just
honestly rattles me um because when i
came to like my first time
um with the lines at this it was like i
was 18 and they did like a i don't know
those pre-season games um
i walked in late to a meeting i was
probably like seven minutes late to a
meeting and as i was i slid in
as gibber was was telling was talking so
he was talking facing facing his back to
me and i literally just slid in the sit
down and he as he i sat down he turned
and i was like and he just carried on
talking [ __ ] but i remember writing we
split into groups when he spilled into
groups probably doing like what do you
want to get out of this week and then i
was like yeah they're like talking
you're right i said yeah and i remember
just a lot of
shaking riding
and
the bottom of the boys look at me like
this can't sound no good but i i was
like
and then they're like can you talk and i
was trying to speak and articulate my
words but bro i was
rattled um
and
those sorts of memories hold me so
yeah i haven't really been lying to
anything since since those incidents
because yeah oh and this other time i
was late to it i was actually late again
to this lineup meeting and he just he
just went off or he just was like
whittle up over where you been
we did the lineup meeting and then left
and i was i was trying to get back in
his good books to talk so i took them i
was like
hey give her like what do you reckon if
i if i jump here and bro he's like mate
don't don't come see me bro go see the
player i was trying to walk off and he
goes
[Music]
and i walk down you know and you know
how in the in the caves thing how you
can it's the coaches officers on top and
you walk downstairs yeah but you you
walk past all like the you walk past
like the train here and there and i'm
walking past nellis they're looking at
him in the last spot
i will park because everyone could hear
me and i walked downstairs and all the
players all those
and i'm just like going in the kitchen
[ __ ]
i'm gonna do today
but yeah i feel like those uh those
things those things strengthened me now
because yeah i'm not really late to
anything else so
i've been good ever since was that one
of the hardest adjustments for you um
that time management
um
yeah probably yeah i think now like i'm
i'm probably like 20 minutes
i'm half half an hour that like most
things happen already the most things
because
yeah
if i'm if i'm like i don't know what
sometimes i will go to next week
i'll go to nexus house for um
for
lunch break and you'll be like oh we'll
get back at 12 30 but our training is
warm up is that one or something like
bro can we just get here at 12 15.
because i'm like i don't need i can't
even deal with this head noise so yeah i
don't know it's probably one of the main
things that i've had to work on which is
uh which is uh served me right so
right but you've nailed it and you
nailed it in time for your move up to
the chiefs and how was your move up to
the chiefs like um you mentioned just
found out that you were having twins
yeah how did you feel once you found out
you were having twins at that age i was
20 when we when i had the kids um
20 she's
it was yeah i thought it was pretty cool
actually like i'd like
i always knew with kayla my partner that
would this would be this was like my
master plan was to be with her forever
so like when we found out we're having
kids i was like yes sweet this is this
isn't like a one-night stand where i
have to sort of worry about this and
madness and that so it was it ended up
being being sweet um
and it was just exciting like i was sort
of just open-minded about everything and
listened to a lot of people's stories
and um
tried to get me to read books and stuff
but a lot of the books i was reading
were about having one kid and just now
i'm like
you're not helping me with this one
kid's one kid chat so
i was sort of just super open minded and
then
we had the kids during lockdown um for
which for us was was really mean because
if we didn't have lockdown i would have
been
in uh south africa or something so um
lockdown ended up working well for us um
but yeah it was
it was exciting and new and um i
honestly was not prepared for anything
um
and i had no idea what was in store for
me so
yeah i've sort of just been uh making
enough on the way
as we all do
a yeah
man
some things aren't yeah
so but then you had to move up to um
hamilton
without obviously your help from your
parents or her parents yes you and your
missus two kids how did you find that
yeah so that that for us was was me and
i like we had them in lockdown
up here and um
we didn't have any help
we didn't have anyone to sort of
you know help us out with anything we
just sort of just had to figure it out
on ourselves and for us it sort of like
strengthened us and we sort of realized
um
what what worked and what didn't work
and then we went to live with them we're
like maybe we can we'll go back to
wellington and
um the our families will help us but we
went back tomorrow and we're like [ __ ]
let's go back up because everyone's like
you need to know this you need to do
that
don't do this don't do that we're like
mate like we've been here we've already
been doing this for weeks for like a
couple months like we know how to we
know how to do this and then everyone's
trying to chime in so it ended up being
detrimental when we went down and um had
uh advice from parents you know but they
you know they just love us and they're
they're trying to um give us the best
advice that they got or their their
learnings but
yeah it was sort of um
it was sort of good for us not having
anyone around us to to help us out sort
of like a sink or swim moment and um
yeah it sort of uh put us in good stead
i guess i like that and what was the
hardest adjustment for you
uh
probably just the sleep a lot
i was just a zombie for for a long time
and then [ __ ] i honestly blew way out
way out my skinnies were like 170 when i
came back
170.
which if you don't if you know skinnies
they're horrendous if you don't know
skinnies that's um that's what you call
way way way off um
yeah i remember coming i just stopped
training i like because we didn't know
at the time if level two meant footy
and then i remember we're going back to
one tonight made the manager like what
does level two look like
he was like nah it'll be the same as
everything else like
you don't have to we won't be back
playing anytime soon and all the zoom
cause we're saying we don't know if the
season is going to go ahead so i was
like mate the seasons are going ahead
like i'll just train later and then i
hadn't really trained and they were like
but they announced level two we were
playing footy
i remember when i heard that and [ __ ] my
heart just sank because i was so sloppy
and i was like oh bro even when i even
when i listen to the the announcement
like some guys like i remember last year
they were playing it like just reviewing
a 2020 season and it like it sort of
just like startles me i don't even know
the sound of it the sound of the i just
remember going i remember when they
happen i'll go [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] i'm done um and then
i try to train and i remember i remember
the training that i did and i remember
like i couldn't even do it and i
remember thinking halfway through like
i'm not even going to survive to say and
then i went back up
and then i remember
um taking my top off to show my rig to
the trainer to do my skinny he was like
what the [ __ ]
i was like he said what have you been
doing i remember saying to him i was
saying someone's like yeah i haven't
been i haven't really been training and
he was like what have you been doing i
was like yeah like i said i haven't been
training he's like
bro he's there and then there's this and
then i remember he was like doing the
pictures
and
he the guys were like on their laptop
and he would say the number and they
were like
and then they will go
and they'll grab the thing and [ __ ]
they will try and they're like
oh bro and i will just think [ __ ]
yeah
so yeah lockdown helped as a as a parent
but it didn't help as a professional
because here
i went
backwards well that is massive so what
were your skinnies normally normally
give us a sort of comparison uh
probably like in the 90s
yeah
that's probably spinning a bit of a yarn
[Laughter]
oh yeah they were like height like high
90s and then lockdown happened then
yeah went up about 70 or whatever
that's so good what were you doing like
what were you eat was it
nutrition or just not training obviously
you weren't training but what were you
eating
yeah i was trying for the first couple
first couple weeks i was training and
eating sweet and then
um
bro once they
had uber eats or flipping like takeaway
deliveries come into lockdown that's all
she wrote like
we would like sleep it
i wouldn't know whether to sleep at six
o'clock because at night and then wake
up at nine o'clock and then we'll just i
would like get to six o'clock wake up at
nine o'clock twelve o'clock five o'clock
and then by the time was five o'clock i
was like i'm not even in the mood to get
up here and then we'll just start
ordering [ __ ] whatever one day we'll
be like let's just try the macas one
because we haven't because we haven't
tried anything oh yeah we'll just try
because then right we just ran through
the whole of [ __ ] hamilton
every takeaway in hamilton and uh
yeah yeah it didn't work out well for us
oh
how long did it take you to um drop that
uh probably
uh
start a preseason
um
last year
uh i was just dropping it slowly during
the blind season and then um their off
season trained real well
um talked to
a few guys at the moana which was like
their moana that we played the maoris
yeah um they had heaps of good advice i
took a lot of guys and then um came in
came in a good nick
um last year's preseason
so yeah i don't know how long that was
but
probably six months or something
which was a long time but um yeah i've
been i've been good ever since which has
been which has been good and i've had a
few we've had a few lockdowns since so
i've uh i've definitely made a few
shifts which has been uh pleasing
mate and you're looking shredder it's
good to see that you're learning from
these mistakes that you've um made
throughout your career man i can't wait
to see you in a in a couple of years
that's it hopefully uh hopefully um i
don't fall back on those sorts of uh
those sorts of slip-ups it's funny i
remember we played we played the
highlanders
first round after um
lockdown
like 2020 when i was sloppy and bonzi
was he came and talked to me and another
guy however mentioned his name either
but he talked to me another guy's like
you guys are [ __ ] lucky you're
playing if i headed my way you'd be out
for the entire season watching everyone
play until you get you get fit enough
blah blah blah i remember thinking
holy i gotta do all this here um but
yeah i ended up i ended up playing all
right eight years which is [ __ ] i
look back in there and what and i just
think how the hell
am was i running around like that
how the hell was i playing like 80
minutes um
which yeah i don't know what was what
was going on there but yeah
it worked well for me i guess
you got there in the end and you
mentioned that moana versus maori's game
um i have heard from the great alex
mankeville that there was a pissing do
after that and you were obviously
leading the charge give me the rundown
on that
yeah
um
it was unreal yeah
we finished the game
obviously it was in hamilton so i sort
of knew
um
hamilton town at the time which was a
blessing and then
i we went to house on hood which is the
main club um
i sort of
caught up with sean waneu and
who are sort of my
bender buddies um
which might come and come out a bit
later in the in the yarn but um yeah we
just yeah we sort of uh get after and
then
i got kicked out of the house because i
try to climb on the balcony to take a
photo of quinn who was on the other side
of the table i could have just walked
around but i
climbed i don't know what i was up to
and come to the balcony and the guy's
like get out and then i left the house
and heard it probably like two o'clock
and then over to toyota's house triple
t's house um and then
we partied from two
to about
seven um and that was mean like it was
cool because it was the moana guys um
and the maori's guys and we just came
together and it was like a real cool
connection there was a few guys like
some of the coaches were there probably
won't name names because
no one wanted yeah they want to name
names but um some of the like deals
coaching staff and management at the
party and it was like bro this is mean
to have um two different teams come
together and
um we just played reggae all night and
then i was like seven o'clock
and i knew i was i had the flight
and my flight was at nine and i knew i
could i wasn't going to get back that
night so i like packed my bag up left
the key
in under the door and my parents had
come to the game
got about seven o'clock
and i was like i just want to keep
hiding and i called my mom who was in
hamilton and i was like mom can you
can you pick up my bag it's it's it's
room number blah blah blah
and i'll just i'll just see it in
wellington and then she
yeah she picked up my bag um
and then i was trying to call the
um the moana manager to change my flight
i was like just change it change it
changes that probably can't change it
your flight's in an hour
and then yeah so i had to
work i just had war whatever i was
wearing to town to the airport got to
the airport hadn't slept and then i
walked into the lounge and like pity
whippy was there and shannon paku in
there and i was like shannon
like
hurricanes baby hurricanes and then kate
haynes was there i was like kane
oh bro just i was just like walking
around trying to like trying to drink a
beer and then i was talking to pretty
whipping i was like betty's ticky toy
get me in the ticky toys by taking tours
and i remember just they're just like
like they don't want to borrow me and i
was like oh this is so bad
and then yeah i got home
slept like for an hour on the airport in
the on the plane right home and then
i came back and my missus like
go to bed i'll wake you up in the
afternoon which was like
how good i mean yeah just slept for a
couple of hours woke up sweet
but yeah it was honestly but i looked
back at that night and that was one of
my that was one of the most enjoyable
nights
um
that i just did not want to end but yeah
it was a big one too all time oh what a
day and i know you i apparently you do
you go really good on a do and um next
obviously spoke about his six-day bender
at the chiefs
gave some good insight on his podcast
apparently you were leading the charge
on that one too
any memories from that or all blur into
one
um no it's funny thing as i remember
most of it um
yeah i was probably mvp um
i think
i think next
probably most improved because he yeah
started off slow yeah uh when got up a
bit and then he sort of just fizzled out
in the end
that wednesday was our end of year do um
so that's why that's why when we drank
on saturday and i knew the end of your
deals on wednesday i was like why do i
why do i why should i stop and then go
again why don't i just keep going which
yeah
ask yourself if that's a good idea or
not but yeah it did the wednesday
that's when i've seen i was dead the
wednesday
and max had been coming in
people coming in every now and then and
then that wednesday i was like man do
you want to embark on this journey like
this journey that we're going on he was
like yeah yeah yeah and then took him on
the journey wednesday um
went to wednesday all the way to
thursday um and then ended up stopping
friday morning and then next had woken
up i don't know if he's explained to me
he woke up and then he didn't know he
didn't know it was friday he thought it
was thursday
and he had missed the entire he had
missed did he say that
bro and i remember sitting back and he
goes is it friday like he's getting up
and i'm like yeah but everybody's frying
yeah he i remember him do you mean like
like so red or nice like he's like i
missed
everything on thursday yesterday
it was one of the biggest uh things i've
ever been a part of friday saturday
night to friday
morning and then probably just took like
four weeks off
just trying to survive
and it was yeah yeah ended up they
didn't bring it it ended up being a
shambles trying to get home
um
my missus had to fly up and then oh she
drove up with friends and we flew back
to wellington
and then my parents had to drive up pack
my house and then drive all my stuff
down
because i was lost
who had the twins
uh
[Laughter]
who hit the twins bro that was the least
of my worries at that point in time i
was honestly trying to survive a who had
the twins bro that was probably one of
the greatest questions that i have never
even thought about the thing was is that
what had happened she had she had she
had already left the week and then she
had already given me the week off the
week yeah um in hamilton like alone so i
i was like can i just drink
can i just drink all week she goes yeah
just make sure you make sure you pick
the hat like the only thing is just pack
the house and drive on friday
and i remember going yeah like sweet i
remember it being thursday and going bro
like i just thought it was like you know
if you sometimes you drink and the next
day you just like you're able to do it
i just thought i was able to do it and
it got to friday and i was like bro
there's no way i can even move i
couldn't even move
oh yeah i wouldn't explain why but yeah
yeah and then yeah they came and saved
my life eh and then i remember just
being
under the pump for a couple weeks so
but yeah
oh the big one the big one yeah that is
a big one the mindset to push your body
through that oh yeah
that's the thing bro you know i was
pushing my body through 160 mils of skin
folds like if you can do that you can
push the days of you know good times
living oh man you're like the david
goggins
i think i should write a book about
digging deep through the tough times and
persevering because there's light at the
end of the tunnel which probably might
my end of my new year's resolution is
like
when it gets to 12 o'clock at night on
the post and then there's a ride home
for me like a free ride home someone's
saying let's go home bro like we can go
get a fair night i'll i would always say
no
this is my new like new year's
resolution is to just just get in the
car mate just get in the car and go home
just take it so yeah sometimes i try to
kick on off the town then i won't take a
free ride home i'll go to you know party
and then
there's like the party is only like half
an hour and i realized i've missed a
free ride i've missed the free feed you
know i've missed my own bed i have to
sort of sort all this stuff out so my
new year's resolution is to sort of just
take the free ride when it comes and
just get out of here so
i've learned from those i've learned
from those mistakes as well it's
constant throughout this podcast you're
making mistakes but you're learning from
them that's awesome
that's growth man the show's growth huge
growth and i'm sure a lot of listeners
can probably take some of this
growth and apply it without having to
make these mistakes yeah yeah don't yeah
two things in there that you probably
shouldn't do um so that's probably one
of them
yeah
who had the kids bro who had my kids
that's a [ __ ] that's a horrendous
dead moment
oh my god who had your kids though when
you were on the piss for six days
i hadn't even have an answer for that
today
that surrender
i do love my kids though and i've
learned from that as you can tell after
you know yeah
you're a learner oh
yeah
i'm a learner the other move in your
career was um the move across the bar
plenty
where did this one come from um
i
wanted to stand like
live closer to the chiefs um
my decision was to sort of do i signed
with the chiefs i was off contract last
year some of the chiefs
and liver in that area or do i
slam with the canes and then go back
home and just park up back home
ultimately i wanted to
to stay here at the chiefs just because
of guzzler coming back and
having a lot of those guys
around me to learn from and then i was
sort of
thinking about where i would want to um
where i would want to sorry play in my
might attend inviting this cup whatever
it's called now
around uh the chief's chief sort of
region um
and i don't i don't want to live in
waikato but hamilton sorry for 12 months
so that was like
sweet i didn't do that
and then the bay had come
the bay would come and oh sorry in that
2020 bender
on the sunday
so saturday sunday i was talking so much
[ __ ] and i was like damn each other
get me to the bay talking to all the all
the baby boys and they were like bro
i'll call clayton now and you tell them
and i was like [ __ ] yeah and then called
clayton i was like kaiten like give it
to them
so yeah and then and then i was off
contract last year and he actually come
see me seriously like wait were you
talking [ __ ] or do you actually want to
come around i was like
[ __ ] and then i talked to a lot of guys
at the bay like chase um carpe he was
there
um to toyota a lot of those guys and
adam ross
and they're like bro it's so nice over
here it's good living and i would play
good footy and blah blah and then
sean wainu was he he was off contract
with the neck and he was wanting to sign
there and i was like oh right this is
like tutorial was there and shawn you're
there like one of my close mates up here
i was like man it would be no brainer
for me to just sort of come with him and
jump on there jump in their party so i
ended up heading to the bear plenty yeah
two years last year this year and
hopefully trust the ground i love that
but you have mentioned um
the great sean wainui a couple of times
so i feel like we uh do need to talk
about that um how did that moment affect
your life
yeah it was crazy oh god
i remember i remember where i was i was
with my kids
um in colburni wellington and
tutorial had mailed me about and i was
like
i just shook and then called him
he talked about some stuff and i was
like all right then i so i was out of
town um
all of us were out of town so i was out
of town
tutorial was a family english females
with family because also we were all
living together at one time
and then
yeah so i had a flight i'll change my
flight to that day and went up that day
and then
yeah it was like a lot of it was surreal
um the entire week was like
it was it was just like it just felt
like a movie um and then we went to the
tongi and then it was it was only until
i left gizzy
that i was like holy like
we had done the burial and stuff and
then we were at the
the the burial and then i remember when
i was leaving that's when it hit me i
was like oh this guy's like this is this
is so real and
um
yeah it's been a hectic hectic like
couple
couple months and
especially
coming back to work um after the summer
and
not having
shawnee there and tutorial who is um he
was he's at the crusaders so i knew at
that you know um before that the
tutorial was going to the seder so i was
like man this is cool like i'll just
i'll have shawnee blah blah blah and
then
coming to work and then both of them not
being now i was like this is yeah hectic
and then um
yeah it's been it's been uh it's been
i can't even explain today like
some days just get me heaps and some
like stuff i'm driving to work and i
listen to a song it reminds me of you
know a memory or like it's a song that
shawn you showed me i'll just be like
holy [ __ ] and then
um we did a lot of like little things
around shawnee um within the team and
those just broke me as well like
um
if i watch something of shawnee like we
watch something i'll just get emotional
and that sort of stuff and we had a call
had a cool moment against the playing
the primaries was sorted out
uh
a memorial game whatever it's called for
shawnee and that was an emotional week
i remember crying before during the warm
up
and then
yeah doing a mean hucka for him after
that game and
um i was emotional seeing his family and
whatnot um
but yeah i guess yeah i don't know what
what sort of grief journey um i'm on at
the moment or how long it's going to
take i feel like it'll take a long time
but
it's just one of those things i guess in
life where um you're in this earth you
know on this earth for one time and then
you're not so
sort of part and parcel of life
i'm still trying to figure it out um but
yeah it's been crazy man
right so sad because he was such a lad
and he was the man but like
when i first came into the chiefs i
didn't know anyone
um and he was like one of the first guys
to come and approach me and just sort of
like make me feel at home there was one
thing i loved about the chiefs was that
um
everyone that when i first came in
when i first came in i thought um brodie
was still at still at the chiefs i
didn't know he was going to sabbatical
so i was like [ __ ] i need to just i need
to fight brody first day and try and
earn some respect here but i just
thought that's what it took for me to
sort of like um get some respect and
then i came in and then guys like
shawnee and guys like peter gus all
these random guys i didn't met hadn't
met um they just came young to me first
day
there's one thing i love about the
chiefs
but yeah he was the man um he had just
had his his son kawariki so now i was
just having my kids so he always talk to
him about um
bad things and
this and that and asked little questions
and he would always ask how my family
were going and whatnot and then
we sort of found
um found out we liked to bend together
so that was something that we uh we
enjoyed giving the monks
he also liked regal music he loved it a
lot um and then he he also loved the
water which is something that we both
shared and
it was pretty cool to have someone like
him
um
sort of be like have the same wavelength
um with me and heaps of heaps of
similarities in my life so that was cool
and then he was he was like
a hundred percent
on being himself he always he was always
himself no matter what like you listen
to interviews and then he's just the
horry going on to you and you listen to
him talk he's the same dude like i
remember when i came i came in like
played in my i painted my toenails at
the base and
season he was like
i showed him he was cracking up and
um
asking me like why are you doing this
for all the line and i was just like bro
i just want to be mean he he was like
but it's mean and he was explaining like
when he was at the nike people were like
telling him to put shoes on he was like
[ __ ] there like blah
um
so it was he was always like bro you
just got to be you like just be you it
you know whatever whatever time and
just be real the whole time so there was
one
real cool thing that
i probably learned off him um
but yeah probably he was like a weapon
um
i would get on the piss and still run
like a 428 bronco
he was like the definition of gary on
your back and i i have no idea how guys
at home can do that there's certain guys
that i've met i've come across in my
footy career that that are just true
weapons like that that can just
you know sing pissed and just back it up
he was one of those guys but
yeah he was the man there was one thing
that i cannot replicate from that dude
oh but you were spot on about him being
always himself i remember him as like a
young i think he must have been 18 or
something coming into the neck
um and he was completely what you said
even from that young age where most guys
are quite shy and
um bit standoffish but he was just
straight away comfortable to get up and
speak like you say very horribly yeah
he owned his personality and it was so
cool and refreshing to see
hmm i think i was a bad boy
yeah gutted mate so sad hey so sad but
we will we do we'll crack on um
to you um what are your plans going
forward mate
i've got
one more year next year next year's my
last year the chiefs and then this is my
last year with the with the bay
you want to be a chief for life or
what's the girls all blacks
yeah yeah i
yeah i want to be an all black um
i want to be an all black hundred
percent um i love i love the chiefs i
would
i'd love to stick around here for
as long as i can um
and i'd love to get to japan after all
of that as well make some
good year have you have you thought
about potentially looking to
change um franchises obviously you say
you love the chiefs but have you seen
potentially opportunities at other
franchises where you yeah
you're getting a bit more minutes and
potentially be their main lock instead
of you know having to scrap with three
other all blacks for game time
uh yeah i guess like
the reason i stayed here was
um yeah
to learn off those guys so that was sort
of a decision that that i made that i so
i can't get upset with the way i'm with
where i'm at in this and my you know
at the season so i'm competing with the
best um
and yeah i guess there's probably an
opportunity if i'm
uh
moved to sort of
be
um playing good footy with bigger
minutes um coming home would be cool i
guess that would be
like a big dream for me to to fulfill um
i don't see that happening in the near
future but i guess you never know um
but yeah honestly i love it here i like
that the culture here like i was saying
is it's unreal very like everyone here
is good people um
the connections we have
um between each other and also like with
the chiefs region as mean i really enjoy
the fact that like hamilton and the
whole of the chiefs region
get amongst us um
so it's hard for me to it would be hard
for me to say goodbye here um
but it is sort of like as a business
decision probably something that i do
have to look at i'm into my contract
next year and um weigh the options so
we'll see when we get there at the
moment i'm i'm super happy with where
i'm right now made exciting times for
you and that we stint in japan will be
worth plenty
talk to me about um post footy
i know you mentioned in your um
interview that you're pretty keen to get
a gig with stan sport or potentially sky
sport
potentially run your own tv show
you and you and gus would actually run a
very good tv show together um i'd love
to see that gus gus was always talking
about like he would love to have a tv
show like bro
when i when com my career's done bro
i'll just jump in with you and we'll
just we'll just take it to the moon but
um
i'd love to do that yeah i'd love to do
i'd love to do something around diving
and fishing
when i seem pretty pity to his stuff i'm
not like that's me um so that would be
something i really want to look into um
i was also thinking of this podcast
actually should i say now i feel like
you might steal it does anyone i was
there this month can i trademark this i
can't even change this
i don't know what i'm saying uh this
podcast
on a boat so that so i just take people
on a boat and we just fish
and just talk [ __ ] and talk footy into
whatever but we're just fishing
and that's something i was thinking
about like that could be cool because
you know when you when you're fishing
with someone
then you've never met them
one like
once you catch a fish with someone
you're just like best mate
and it all the barriers break down bro
and everyone just you just start [ __ ]
talking about anything and everything
have a few beers
you know we'll just be catching fish and
drop some livers out and
sit there and wait and just
chew the fat um that's something that
would love to do i don't know how how
plausible it is that'd be one of the
great podcasts if i could combine
talking [ __ ] and fishing and make money
from it then by by all means that'll be
me you're living your dream and the
listeners are living their dream
listening to you yeah
100 that's it that's it right there no
ambitions to be a lawyer like your
parents
nah i look just look so stressful like
my parents are lawyers and my sisters
she's a lawyer as well
um
it's just a lot of work out a lot of
work that i probably
probably don't have time for if i'm just
so lazy to do it um but it does seem
pretty cool like
yeah it does seem cool that the stuff
they do like
um helping people and
whatnot but it just looks quite
stressful and i probably i'm not a
stressful guy i don't really get i don't
really like to get stressed i like to
keep things loosely juicy as possible so
yeah putting extra stress on myself
hopefully be detrimental for the rest of
my uh most of my life
but no like probably lawyer's probably a
great job i probably want to i don't
want to beg all the lawyers out there
sorry guys i love you all you know but
yeah
you guys keep doing you i'm gonna keep
doing me
yeah
you stick to your fishing and uh fishing
podcast that one yeah that's a hat for
sure
that's it oh what a story but as always
we have gone to our instagram for some
questions and and that's the legend
himself
we have got plenty of questions coming
for you i have managed to squeeze in
quite a few of them throughout this um
episode already but we'll crack on to
the rest
um
ask him about his nickname machete this
is a good one oh yeah yeah yeah that was
my nickname at school um
i was staying at a friend's house in
tudongi
and we were motorbiking
and then we tried to go through this
bush and we're like [ __ ] we can't go
through this bush oh will get these
machetes
and try and cut through them and this
machete like the i don't know the grass
was taking like two hits to um break
down
every time and then my cousin was
spinning this yarn and she's like
notorious for just telling stupid
stories that have like
endings that have no punchline and then
she was telling that story and i was
hitting them one two cut it one two and
then she ended the story and i was like
that's so bad look back
and instead of this one [ __ ] grass
whatever taking two hits it just took
one i just sliced my knee
um way open and then
i was like [ __ ] i'm done um and then
yeah ever since then at school people
just called me machete and i sort of
just like one of the guys taught said it
and i was like [ __ ] that is the first
thing um
and i just ran with it changed my
facebook name it's a machete and then
it's just right people started chiming
into schools and i was like yeah this is
living
and then yeah no one's not i haven't
really ran this in school but yeah i
would love to bring that back
bring it back write it on the whiteboard
headgear yeah yeah yeah i've actually
got my nickname is actually huhu now
which is um yeah gussy actually gave me
that one gus he gave me that one how did
you get hoohoo um i i got huhu because
i'm like
far from being a grump
so
they just wanted the irony of it
i'm just going to say i'm just going to
leave it at that and probably wouldn't
elaborate too much on
i just re i was thinking about this
probably going to say that but yeah gus
gus um started calling me calling me
hoo-hoo and bro gus is like notorious
for creating nicknames for people
most of our team's nicknames i'm pretty
sure from
from gus so yeah he made that one
oh he's good he's good at that uh he
gets the momentum of the team gets
everyone to buy into it and
it doesn't stop
right because he's just so freaking loud
yeah it doesn't stop so loud just like
this
it worked out in the end i guess okay
next one uh greatest reggae band bro
house of shame is is becoming my
favorite um
they're kiwi band um yeah i probably
listened to them more than any other um
band
um probably right now but yeah but i
went to house of shaman wellington and i
feel
i didn't really know how to shame in
that time so i wasn't reviving it like i
was listening to it and then i got so
wasted and i just started having this
deep and meaningful conversations on the
balcony and missed the whole concert
and then as from that moment on as my
life has carried on i've learned to love
house hashem and i realized i missed
this huge opportunity to watch it in
life because i was so pissed and when i
get pissed by i just start telling
people my life story i just start
thinking i'm a guru in this thinking
mate you need to need you need life
lessons for me because i know everything
about life even though i'm 22
and yeah so
i missed out but yeah house hashem is
probably my favorite um band
at this point in time i like that you're
going to have to get pissed for your um
podcast when you go fishing
that sounds like good stuff right that's
it yeah so it's yeah
it's on the post talking [ __ ] and
[ __ ] fishing that's just three things
that probably made for each other
okay next one uh the next question is
from our major sponsor swish and get
natalia thirty dollars absolute steal
make sure you go get em
if you could get a video shout out from
anyone in the world who would it be and
why
i don't know that's probably a that's a
real question that i'd have to
to sit on
what are you can what do you reckon mate
he's in front of me and i'm going to go
honestly i would have loved to have matt
watson but matt watson came to um
sam kane's birthday party and [ __ ]
when i seen him up i just chewed his
arrow for four hours
and i feel so bad because i was just
fanboying him and he was like i was he
was talking about um i see people asking
about fishing shows and i was like he
was talking about it and i was answering
it with him he was just like us
he's like yeah [ __ ] it that's right but
i was like yeah like it was on three at
nine when you you know
headlined that marlin and he was like
yeah
[ __ ] hot yeah it was not everything
sorry bro i'm a huge fan and i remember
just chewing his air off for hours eh so
maybe what matt watts would have been uh
would be a nice one
but yeah
mate this and there's your first guess
for your fishing podcast hey
if he would if he would if he would come
on i don't know he might be traumatized
after that one incident because yeah
i remember i remember talking to guys
they don't like when people like
bombarding them with things i'm thinking
yeah that that probably sucks and then
[ __ ] once he got in front of me very
like he probably wanted to leave a and i
was just
did he never give me a really good
hours hours
oh i love it okay next one is he a
professional dancer
bro i would love to i would love to uh
give that a crack probably not as good
as um
probably not as good as that the best of
the best but
mate
i'm not you know i'm gonna let it all
hang out if the music good you know i
mean
i probably probably had a good uh good
performance when i had went on my
wedding um
last week put on a good show for the for
the crowd which is uh
something i always love to do so yeah
not a professional dancer but good on
hey
family man come see me come see me yeah
good good on the dance good on the dance
floor i'd say are you a sober dancer are
you happy to get up there sober and just
completely cut shapes right
yeah
honestly but music just touches my soul
and if if i if i walk in
and and this is a song that just hits me
where it is like
there's nothing stopping me
and yeah i'm pretty like
i'd probably dance
all the time i dance in the gym i'll
dance before the game i dance in the
warm up i'm done i'm warming up by
dancing
and then any time of the day if
if there's a song that touches my soul
it could be anything i'm like
i love all kinds of music and if yeah if
at any point there's a song that touches
my soul then
i'm i'm i'm out there i'm out there
doing it
so if you were going to run a bronco
would you warm up by via dance no
bronco's [ __ ] way off they're just
rattling yeah i'm just
i don't even
you know when you run a bronco i don't i
don't even think i can talk before a
bronco and i'm a big talker i'm pretty
sure i'm a mute before bronco my legs
are just jelly
if all of a sudden my heart rate's
beating i'm trying to just woo star and
wim hof my flipping breath
what is that called i don't even know my
breath hold down but yeah
if you i can't do anything before bronco
you can't ask me anything before bronco
yeah
but if you feel if you hear music you'll
you'll naturally dance
oh if i hear music yeah yeah if i hear
music right that's just
yeah i probably don't even have good
dance memes
this is ellie e right there doesn't see
right there
[Music]
this is my favorite one
[Music]
pull the trigger oh my gosh
oh shout out to lab mate i've been sort
of growing this waterlab concert uh
obviously a lot of acts we've got gus on
the sacks we've got all these guys but
maybe yours is dance but i do know
you're a good singer too
would you be a dancer or a singer first
uh i don't know here i'm
i would like to say i'm above average
singer um
yeah
and i'd probably i would
probably
depends what i got i don't know yeah
i'll probably be drunk obviously um and
then i'll just start sensing
just perform
i would just yeah i'm just a performer
i'm a crowd pleaser i love to give
people a show i'm on the mic i'm just
like put your hands up oh you know we're
leaving that hang and then if a song
comes on that it's that i'm feeling that
i'ma let it go and then
i'll probably just be dancing the entire
time really that would be unreal yeah i
reckon you'd be our finale act
what song would you sing yeah and could
you give us a little snippet just to
sample so we can sell some tickets
i'm actually [ __ ]
i'm actually out of breath from there
done um what is the song that i would
sing
what would you like to hear what would
you like to like what would the genre be
um it's open to anything obviously we've
got a delve by jeremy thrash already
um we've got tom robinson and
99.9 gigabytes so we've got a bit of a
mix going on already
um celica rassi with impressions dj brad
webber
um dj blackadder with abba remixes
there's a few acts going on yeah yeah
and then we finish with the finale
finale
natalia with the performance of the year
yeah see the thing if you if if you're
gonna if you're gonna put me on a finale
you know it'd have to be a finale sort
of sort of jam i don't know if i have a
finale jam for you oh we could open with
you we could open with you so everyone
gets there early i would like to
probably just
open it
sort of come in in the middle and come
in at the end
and then come with the encore and they
come at the after party yeah i'm their
kind of guy but if you give me a mic to
perform it's so hard for me to just come
off stage and let someone outside that's
very probably get a bit selfish with the
limelight well you could you could open
and then just stay up there with all the
acts so while dj brad webb is up there
you could be yeah see i was thinking
dancing
dancing yeah that was me it's funny he's
got real good mixes there we'll just
get you going get me going yeah
house of shame
party
see you've got to schedule me skank
i don't know i gotta stand up see that's
the thing the music touches me
oh i can feel it
see this is when the crowd with us oh
and then who who walks in the door
and then the bros on the six
this is a part oh
[Music]
i see i'm dancing
[Music]
i'm out of breath so actually
what a performance sorry get me my
ticket i need to have another shelf i'm
actually sweating that is unbelievable
oh my gosh yeah
how's the shoe bro one of the great
that song honestly bro if you play at a
party with brown people it just goes
oh
tracker tracker
and if you're on the djos yeah
[ __ ] there it is
sorry for another time
oh mate what what a performer water
performance
if you can't see this and you're just
listening to this episode you have just
missed one of the biggest performances
of
dancing you will ever see so go check it
out on youtube or have to clip this or
the instagram because oh that was
something special but we've got two more
questions i'm sorry to bring you back
down to
yeah that's good
we've got this one's a code question too
um
best luck in world rugby
this one came in a few times people want
to know your thoughts yeah i'd say
guzzler i'd say um it's probably i've
only really watched
uh new zealand and aussie uh locks
um i know
murray he told you he's probably gone i
haven't really watched too much of his
footy but where i sing seeing guzzler um
first hand is like
his work is like the way he trains and
then also like him on the field
the dude's got no like no let up play
like he's just got a motor that keeps on
keeping on and
his heimits are like on par with the
wingers you know
he's just
like a million miles an hour
into everything
it doesn't seem like he gets tired
and um yeah hell of a grub too so that
helps a lot
um
yeah so i'd say i'd say
yeah now fair enough hard to argue he is
he is a lad okay last question um best
piece of advice you have for a woodland
listener uh
i'll probably just say bu i think that's
probably the theme of of uh of this
probably podcast that i've been on um
probably
when i had i remember having painted
toenails and wanting to then like
probably didn't get
as good as
getting get much love but i sort of just
like stuck to it and now now here i am
just flipping everything painted on so
yeah i think
if you can um be an opportunity
to speak or be in a stage where um
people are watching um and you're
yourself then
you'll look back and be like that's cool
um that was something that i really
wanted to as a professional i wanted to
um
to keep hold of
when i was at school i wanted to
make sure that i didn't change up on
people or didn't become someone i wasn't
so yeah to sort of be in chief's
environment they've let me be myself
this whole time and um i've sort of just
been run with it now because as you can
see i'm dancing on a podcast and
talking smack on a bloody
stand sport and wearing you know
toenails cleaning out painted everything
so yeah oh i'll probably just have to
stay there though pretty cliche again
mate i love it
i love it where did you get your um love
for painting your toenails and nails
where did that sort of start
um i
[Music]
wanted to i painted my toenails once um
before under 19s and then
i just thought that's pretty funny and
then i remember coming to the lines and
people just roasted me
i went yeah they just roasted me and i
was like for swedes
and then just sort of was like man if
people don't like it then i sort of like
i sort of like that even more that
people don't like it um
and then i always wanted to get my
my
fingernails um painted but
i thought that that was pretty like
that was like pushing it in terms of um
people hating on me but
i just thought man
here i am why don't i just flip and
run it um
so yeah i've always wanted to give my my
fingernails painted and no one had done
it um and i knew that people didn't like
it
and i was sort of like
[ __ ] that's kind of cool so yeah yeah
maybe i don't know is that like me being
defiant or me being a rebellious i don't
know yeah it's you being a lad yeah me
being led here i'll take that i'll take
that
oh my absolute legend love that um and
love this podcast obviously um we speak
about the whole sort of reason i started
this podcast was to give people an
insight into what guys are really like
off the field and i probably didn't even
need this podcast with you because
people have seen what you really like
off the field because you're yourself in
front of the cameras anyway but um
awesome to get an insight on your
journey and
see the real you and
i know so many people wanted to hear
from you hear the whole story so i think
they'll be
definitely happy with what they received
and hopefully they can see some of those
moves and and we can get you
um
at this concert performing get your head
gear with the um whiteboard humming
sails through the roof and
i'm looking forward to
listening to your podcast your fishing
podcast with a few beers
i'm listening looking forward to
listening to that on my way to work 100
100
thank you so much for letting me uh come
on and yeah i'm happy that i'm like
you're giving a platform for people to
be themselves and let people see the
real the real life i guess because
there's a lot of people who
are scared to uh beat themselves because
of
people getting ridiculed so it's awesome
to have a platform here where we can
just open up and do our thing i guess so
yeah cheers for that mate you're a lad
you're a legend my friend